short term hold cash  five years or less hold cash  long term own equities but real estate  is also not a terrible option provided  it is unlevered and you don't you don't  have too much or any  debt against it commodities like gold  and silver are not a terrible option but  they are inferior for the long term  uh because they don't have as much  appreciation as equities do  they're also inferior for the short term  because their prices will fluctuate  but for the short term  we have to choose between  depreciating cash  and variable price on commodities  my choice would be cash but it's a  reasonable thing to say that i'm going  to hold some gold and silver uh for your  interest lastly  my plan  is to spend the rest of my life never  from now till i die i will never have  owned any gold or silver and i feel very  confident that i'll do just fine